Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute zeig ich euch endlich mein mega leckeres Rezept für Tiramisu!
Mein leckeres Tiramisu Rezept kommt ganz ohne rohes Ei aus und auch ohne Alkohol.
Nun will ich euch aber nicht lange auf die Folter spannen und zeig euch jetzt zunächst einmal die Zutaten.
Wir benötigen kalte Schlagsahne, Mascarpone, Doppelrahmfrischkäse,
außerdem Puderzucker, Sahnestandmittel, Vanillezucker,
kalten Kaffee (ihr könnt da Espresso nehmen oder starken Kaffee, so wie ihr möchtet),
ein paar Löffelbiskuits und für die Deko Backkakao.
In meine Küchenmaschine mit dem Schneebesenaufsatz geb ich jetzt
zuallererst Mascarpone und Frischkäse.
Wer keine Küchenmaschine da hat, der kann selbstverständlich
auch das Handrührgerät verwenden
und sobald dann beide Frischkäse Sorten in der Schüssel sind,
geben wir Puderzucker und Vanillezucker mit hinzu.
Jetzt wird das Ganze ganz kurz miteinander verrührt, also wirklich
nur ein paar Sekunden, bis sich alles einigermaßen verbunden hat.
Nun geben wir die kalte Schlagsahne mit hinzu und es ist ganz wichtig,
dass die Sahne kalt ist und frisch aus dem Kühlschrank kommt, also nicht
erst ein paar Minuten auf Zimmertemperatur lag.
Nun wird das Ganze gemeinsam mit der Sahne aufgeschlagen und an der Stelle
geben wir auch unser Sahnestandmittel hinzu und dann dauert's nicht lang und
die Creme ist schön fest.
Nun habe ich 1200g von der leckeren Creme und ein Drittel
davon, also 400g gebe ich mir zur Seite in einen Spritzbeutel und
den Rest, den bearbeite ich direkt weiter.
Ich nehme hier meine große Auflaufform(die Maße schreib ich euch
unten in die Infobox, damit ihr einen Vergleich habt)
und stelle mir auch meinen kalten Kaffee und meine Löffelbiskuits bereit.
Nun tunken wir unsere Löffelbiskuits in den Kaffee und zwar wirklich nur 1 bis
allerhöchstens 2 Sekunden, lassen das kurz abtropfen und geben das dann in die Auflaufform.
Und so machen wir nun weiter, bis der Boden der Auflaufform komplett bedeckt ist.
Wer keinen Kaffee mag, der kann selbstverständlich auch Kakao machen
und die Löffelbiskuits dann in Kakao tunken. Eine weitere Variante
wäre auch Orangensaft oder jeden Saft, den ihr gerne habt
aber die klassische Variante ist selbstverständlich mit Kaffee.
Nun gebe ich mir etwas mehr als die Hälfte der Creme, die in meiner Schüssel noch übrig ist
auf die Löffelbiskuits. Ich gebe mir mehr als die Hälfte darüber denn
wir haben uns ja gerade in dem Spritzbeutel noch ein wenig Creme zur Seite gelegt
und so ist das Creme : Löffelbiskuit Verhältnis einfach perfekt
und wir haben gleichmäßige Schichten.
Nachdem die Creme einigermaßen glatt gestrichen wurde, geben wir
die nächste Schicht Löffelbiskuits darüber, tunken sie auch wieder kurz in den Kaffee
und gießen dann selbstverständlicherweise auch etwas Kaffee nach,
wenn das nicht ganz ausreicht.
Wichtig ist wirklich nur, dass der Kaffee komplett ausgekühlt ist,
denn ansonsten verträgt sich der warme Kaffee nicht mit unserer Creme.
Sobald auch die zweite Löffelbiskuit Schicht auf der Creme ist, geben wir
die restliche Creme aus der Schüssel darüber und streichen es glatt,
das muss allerdings nicht SO schön glatt sein, denn
wir geben gleich noch mehr Creme darüber.
Damit nämlich auch die Dekoration hübsch aussieht, werde ich
die restliche Creme jetzt pünktchenweise darüber verteilen
und hier reicht es aus, wenn ihr euren Spritzbeutel vorne einfach nur abschneidet,
da braucht ihr keine spezielle Tülle dafür.
Und sobald ihr dann fertig seid, muss das Ganze nur noch kühlen.
Mindestens 4h lang gehört das Ganze jetzt in den Kühlschrank,
dann wird alles schön fest.
Ich hab's in meinem Fall über Nacht stehen lassen und
am nächsten Tag ging's dann weiter
und ich hab das Ganze einfach nur noch mit Backkakao bestreut.
Den Backkakao gebt ihr am besten auch wirklich erst vor dem Verzehr darüber,
denn ansonsten kann das im Kühlschrank feucht werden
und dann sieht er einfach nicht mehr schön aus.
Und somit ist unser klassisches Tiramisu auch schon fertig
- für mich die allerbeste und leckerste Variante.
Ich bin mir sicher es gibt unzählige andere Varianten, allerdings
freue ich mich, wenn ihr meine dann mal ausprobiert und mir Feedback da lasst.
Die Löffelbiskuits sind super weich geworden und die Creme ist so schön
standfest; schaut mal wie toll der Anschnitt aussieht!
Ich bin super gespannt auf euer Feedback und natürlich
auf eure nachgemachten Fotos, z.B. auf Instagram mit #kikiskitchen.
Ansonsten bedanke ich mich fürs Einschalten und freue mich,
wenn ihr beim nächsten Mal dann auch wieder dabei seid!
Tschüss!